okay so how many of you have used the
app face app
the app that lets you see your face is
if you're old young a man
a woman well they recently came out with
an update that lets you see your face
with racial features there's a mix of
opinions about this there's some people
who think the technology is cool and
there's some people who are kind of
taken back by the fact that you're
wearing another person's race as a
filter
the update was taken down but i've got
some receipts and screenshots so we're
gonna see what other people think about
it
have you ever heard of face app i have
heard a face app i have not
like you you turn into an old person or
a baby have you heard about their new
race filter update
i just heard of the app why why why
would anyone do this
so with this update you have the option
to see your faces asian caucasian
indian or black really so basically you
could see yourself
in another race i want to see what i
look like asian
you know i don't know how i feel about
that would you like to see the results
i don't know if this is appropriate
though oh wow
okay wow so we just do digital blackface
all day digital yellow face digital
brown face
it's scary that technology can get to
this point
it's the same way reason i have issues
with people
dressing up being like i'm gonna put on
an afro for a costume it's like you're
wearing my natural hair as like
costumes the technology is interesting
and i understand that you know there is
a curiosity behind seeing like
what would i look like and i think
that's perfectly human but i think that
to put it in
an app kind of devalues another culture
it's coming from a place of privilege
that somebody sat in a room and said
this is okay to do
it's just really playing into like
stereotypes like asians have like
really small eyes darkening people's
skin lightening people's
skin there's no like blanket statement
as to like how one person should look
and this is exactly what the space app
is doing people have a variety of
different
you know facial features skin colors a
little understatement it's pretty
unsettling i remember using the bob
marley one
and i didn't think anything of it and
saw like a whole bunch of people using
it
and like speaking with like jamaican
patois and i was like ah this just feels
weird
my race is not for your entertainment
there's a history behind people
wearing other culture spaces as
entertainment and it not being a good
thing
that should be more than enough to be
like no not a good idea
the fact that this even was even an
update to begin with
just shows like several rounds of people
said that this was okay
maybe they need to reevaluate a few
[Music]
things
[Music]
wow